[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
the final stage of unlocking the country
from coveted restrictions in june
appears to be on course
after it was revealed vaccines are
largely effective against the new indian
variant of the virus
a study by public health england shows
the pfizer and astrazeneca vaccines
are almost as effective against the
variant as they are against the dominant
kent variant
it also shows two doses are far more
effective which could lead to the gap
between injections closing to eight
weeks for everyone
the health secretary says he's
increasingly confident about the
timetable to lift covered restrictions
our political correspondent rob powell
reports in the race between vaccines and
variants jabs just took a leap forward
new data shows the shots that have gone
into millions of arms
do work against the indian covid variant
leading to optimism of a return to
something close to normality
next month i'm increasingly confident
that we're on track
for the road map because this data shows
that the vaccine after two doses works
effect
just as effectively and you know we all
know that the vaccine is our way out of
this
the public health england study shows
two doses of the fisa vaccine
are 88 effective against symptomatic
disease from the indian variant
that compares to 93 for the kent version
while the astrazeneca jab is 60
effective against the indian variant
after two doses
and 66 against the kent variant
the vaccines are expected to be even
more effective
against hospitalization and death
government scientists say the lower
astrazeneca figures may be down to its
rollout starting
after pfizer and the fact that the
vaccine takes
longer to achieve a full immune response
but while the effectiveness of both jabs
after two doses is largely unchanged
against the indian variant
there is more of a difference after one
a single dose of either pfizer or
astrazeneca
was found to be 50 percent effective
against the kent variant
dropping to just 33 against the indian
version
because of this ministers aren't ruling
out bringing
forward second doses to eight weeks for
everyone
not just those who are more vulnerable
so i think there's a balance between
getting the first doses into the younger
people
and making sure that they were
maximizing out the people who are
partially affected protected and then
improving the
vaccine-protected population in the
older population who are
have the most severe disease
hospitalizations and deaths
cases of the indian variants have spread
rapidly in hot spots like bolton and
blackburn
but across the country the kent variant
is still dominant
responsible for a vast majority of
hospitalizations in recent months
whether that stays the case will depend
on how contagious
this new mutation is a key factor that
will dictate if the vaccine
can keep up with the virus rob powell
sky news in westminster
and there'll be more on this when the
home secretary priti patel speaks with
trevor phillips on sunday that's at half
past eight this morning here on sky news
let's take a look now at the latest
covid figures for the uk
there have been 2 694 new cases
six more deaths have been reported which
means the total number of people who've
died within 28 days of a positive test
now stands at 127 716.
meanwhile another 208 310 people
have received their first vaccination
and 411
714 people have received their second
in total 59.79 million jabs
have now been administered across the uk
the journalist at the center of the
controversy over the bbc's interview
with princess diana says he's deeply
sorry
speaking publicly for the first time
since the dyson report was published
former panorama reporter martin beshear
said that he never wanted to harm diana
the report concluded that he'd faked
documents and then used them to secure
the interview
our royal correspondent ran on mills
reports
it's the first time we've heard in
detail from the man at the center of
this scandal
speaking to the sunday times martin
beshear can't bring himself to admit
he was wrong i never wanted to harm
diana
in any way and i don't believe we did he
says
everything we did in terms of the
interview was as she wanted
from when she wanted to alert the palace
to when it was broadcast
to its contents my family and i loved
her
in many ways his comments will only fuel
the demand for answers from the bbc
and others who were involved like former
director general
lord hall whose investigations into
martin beshear and the fake documents
were described
as woeful after calls for him to step
back from public life
he's resigned as chair of the national
gallery
chris blackhurst was one of the
journalists that the bbc
lied to after he asked if bashir had
told diana she was being spied on
there's no way that um lord hall could
have carried on as chairman because i
think i'm right in saying that the
prince of wales is patron
of the national gallery and that would
really really be compromising for him
and whatever he did as chairman of the
gallery every time he did anything or
the gallery did anything
questions about martin bashir and the
princess of wales would always be asked
so it was impossible
but hall's apology doesn't go far enough
for those who believe
this has raised serious questions about
how the bbc
is governed no one is bigger than the
organization
and the need to ensure that when they do
actually
uh uh when they do actually put things
forward the editorial policy unit
actually has
a real say and real clout so it's with
halt withstands or
sorry withholds the um the standards
that you'd expect of our leading public
service broadcaster
some who worked at the most senior
levels within the corporation
agree this is a time to look inward
there was a systemic failure as well as
an individual failure
and correcting that is important for the
individual for the staff involved
involved in the bbc
but it's of course terribly important
for the audience and the licensed
viewpoint
for diana's brother lord spencer it's
the met
police he now wants to act we understand
he's again written to the force
demanding they look further
into the fake bank statements used by
bashir to deceive him
he also alleges diana was a victim of
blackmail
and fraud it has
brought back painful memories for
diana's family
prince william representing the queen as
lord high commissioner of the church of
scotland
unexpectedly spoke about the difficult
days around diana's death
i was in balmoral when i was told that
my mother had died
still in shock i found sanctuary in the
service at crafty kirk that very morning
and in the dark days of grief that
followed i found comfort and solace
in the scottish outdoors i'm told that
prince william is going to continue
working with the bbc on certain projects
but he has made it very clear
that he never wants that interview with
his mother to be shown again
and in some way he wants the bbc to try
and correct that false narrative
that he says it portrayed for so many
years
the interview sparked a chain of events
that rocked the monarchy the queen again
out on public duties visiting hms queen
elizabeth
has of course in recent years weathered
other difficulties
this time her family and her institution
are not under attack but through painful
memories
are still feeling the repercussions
rhiannon mills
sky news also this morning
the uk is to move to a fully digital
border and immigration system
after admitting that for decades it's
been unable to record the number of
people entering or leaving the country
the digital border will allow automated
security checks and will measure
immigrant numbers
an entire city is being evacuated in the
democratic republic of congo in central
africa
after a major volcanic eruption people
are being urged to leave the city of
gomer
after lava reached the outskirts aisha
zahid reports
and molten ash lit up the night sky over
the democratic republic of congo
after one of the world's most active and
dangerous volcanoes erupted
for the first time in nearly 20 years
lava can be seen pouring towards the
capital of gomer
consuming everything in its path
a government evacuation order was issued
to the 2 million residents
and power supplies were cut off
we have to do our best to give you
factual information
unfortunately a part of gomer is in the
dark
but i want to assure you your government
is doing something
as panic sets in locals grabbed what
they could
before leaving the city
here the situation is serious the fire
is becoming complicated the houses are
burned
the people are suffering the problems
are huge
nerogongo last erupted in 2002
when it killed 250 people and left 120
000 homeless clearing the city could
help save lives
but nothing can stand in the way of the
volcano's devastating power
aisha zahed sky news
now there's concern that women seem to
be disappearing from professional
working life as they get older
a new book aims to highlight the issue
of ageism and why it affects women in
particular
one of the co-authors jane evans joins
me now
good morning to you um first of all i
suppose i better ask about
your personal experience in the
professional world
um yes for me i've had a highly
successful advertising career
um and my 50s i tried to re-enter the
business after a couple of years break
and found that i was completely
invisible to my industry
which was a surprise because throughout
my life the one thing that i'd always
been able to rely on was my talent
but i became invisible and faced ageism
to my face
and the book is invaluable to in
invisible um
was it something that you were aware of
that you were experiencing
could you identify and pinpoint exactly
what was happening at the time
um the book is actually called invisible
to invaluable um
and so basically
sorry about that written by me and carol
russell uh basically um i found my
experience
and then actually started a movement to
find out what was happening other with
other women
and when i decided to write about it the
last thing that we thought the world
needed was another book by a white
middle class feminist
so i'm working with black author carol
russell on the on the job
because this is actually a an epidemic
that's hitting all women
um with at the center for better aging
uh made a report last august saying that
um when furlough ends
uh one in ten men over 50 will be facing
unemployment
and eight out of ten women will be
facing unemployment
um i mean those are startling uh figures
and we know that the pandemic has
particularly
affected women in in the professional
arena in terms of you know the
additional domestic duties sometimes
homeschooling
but but for older women it is a very
specific
issue isn't it we we i think because
women of our age have not appeared in
the workforce before
there's a societal narrative that there
isn't a place for us
so we find with professional women round
about 45 it seemed presumed that they
are going to lose their job in the next
round of redundancies
um which is and again women feel as
though it's happening just to them
and then when they realize other women
it's actually happening to them and you
ask younger women to look around the
workforce
and no they're not seeing women between
the ages of 45 and 70.
um we all have to work till we're 17.
we're going to live to win 90.
um and yet we're expected to lose our
careers halfway through our lives
so what what are the solutions that does
the the book
provide any solutions or suggestions for
for women who might face this first of
all for women to know that you are not
alone this is happening to all of us
um and you know they say for millennials
that the future of work is lifelong
learning and multiple careers
we are saying to society this is time to
start now
so for instance um we've started a thing
with wpp and brixton finishing school
which trains um mid-life women in
digital media which is
which there's a massive skill shortage
of and
you know growth area um and so what
we're saying is
let's start the lifelong learning of
multiple careers lets women let women
start a second career
and for many ethnically diverse women
give them an opportunity
to have a first career a professional
career
you describe something as a midlife
power
and releasing that tell us a bit more
about what that entails well especially
when younger women are suffering through
child you know
child care and everything through the
pandemic uh you know women of our age
get a great boost from the other side of
menopause and we have more testosterone
we have more confidence we have more
energy and so
to throw away this this powerhouse of
force
is ridiculous especially when we can do
what we did before
and and pave the way back for these
women that have lost their jobs in the
pandemic
you founded the am i right the
uninvisibility project
that's correct yes that was started
um basically through my experience i
wanted to know
if there were actually only women over
the age of 50 creating ads in london
and that's specifically important
because women are the ones
the creative director is the person who
decides who we see in
in ads um when i started the project i
thought it was just going to be my arena
within two weeks it became apparent that
this was an epidemic and it was across
all areas and it was very very much a
societal narrative
that we do need to change jane evans
thank you so much for speaking to us
this morning you are seen
we see you thank you very much thank you
coronavirus is surging through nepal one
of the world's poorest nations
hospitals are full there's a shortage of
oxygen and ventilators in the country
has run out of vaccines
sky news was given access to one of the
country's main hospitals to witness the
crisis at first hand
a warning you may find this report from
neville lazarus distressing from the
start
the military has been drafted into
picking up covet 19 bodies
that succumb to the virus at home
it's their third one this morning and
they take no chances
as they are called to the home of an 84
year old woman
her last rights are hurriedly performed
by the family
there is little time for mourning and
almost none
for rituals in this deeply religious
hindu community
at one of the largest government
hospitals the conditions are telling
a makeshift center outside as everything
inside the building
is in short supply attached to oxygen
they wait their turn to get a look
inside
doctors and nurses doing their rounds
and monitoring critical levels
patients have come from across the
country as public health facilities in
rural nepal
is woefully inadequate
74 year old bahadur took a six-hour
grueling journey
to find the hospital full the family
has decided to head back to the village
inside they are jostling for space
for some even the floor will do as long
as it's inside
sky news was given access to the
hospital's icu
a month ago there were just 150 daily
cases
now the country reports 8 000
and the second wave has been lethal and
relentless
[Music]
forty nine
each passing day the death rate is
mounting
a month ago the daily average was seven
deaths
it's now almost 200 a day
fear of infections families are not
allowed inside
and grieve from outside the gates
watching and praying from afar
aid agencies have warned the country is
running out of vaccines
the government has appealed for
emergency supplies
as more than a million wait for this
second shot
less than two percent of the population
are fully vaccinated
the pandemic is spreading across the
valleys and mountains of nepal
with more than half a million cases this
impoverished nation
is now grappling to keep its people
alive
neville lazarus sky news
now in a curious experiment scientists
in london have given volunteers a
robotic
third thumb to use on their hands while
it looks useful
what does our brain make of it well
let's speak now to the designer of the
third thumb
danny claude and neuroscientist paulina
caliber good morning
to you both and first of all to you
danny in in simple terms um explain to
us the
idea behind the third thumb and and how
it actually works
yeah sure so the third thumb is a 3d
printed
thumb extension for your hand um
controlled by uh your toes that's
wirelessly connected um
to your big toes and it's all 3d printed
all flexible
and it's a way to extend um the use of
of the hand
and what was the idea behind it is this
for use
for people who have all five um fingers
or
is it for those that might have lost uh
a digit
yeah sure yeah so um it actually came
about uh during my master's degree
project at the royal college of art
and i actually designed prosthetic arms
as well so it was a way to kind of
better understand
um a prosthetic as as technology i
wanted to kind of
understand the relationship that forms
um between kind of a person in a kind of
augmentative technology or prosthetic
technology
and and decided to make an extra thumb
yeah so
um paulina 36 people were given this
prosthetic and monitored before and
after what exactly did you
find what did you learn right so
uh we saw that our participants who were
using this first time for about five
days
i had changes to how their natural hand
is represented in the brain and to be
in the brain to be a little bit more
specific what we observed is that their
natural
hand representation has shrunk so to say
which means that to their brain the way
their individual fingers
are represented became more similar each
finger became a little bit more similar
to the other ones
and um in terms of the other
digits did that um minimize the
use of them what what effect did that
third thumb have on
the hand so we cannot really say that it
had a lot of effect in terms of
how well you're able to use your hand
sort of
um you know mechanically but we saw that
when people were using the third time
they start to use their fingers together
a little bit differently
so instead of for example grasping
everything with five fingers
they would form slightly different
coordination patterns where they would
use for example these two fingers a
little bit more or just two fingers a
little bit more
and uh we think that this is what sort
of draws the changes we see in the brain
which is because people were invited to
incorporate these extra digits into
their hands they started
creating new hand movements and that was
reflected
in how their brain represents perceives
their natural hand
danny were you um surprised by the the
findings is this how you expected the
experiment to pan out no i mean i
could have never known that the this
project could have gone this far it's
it's amazing and actually working with
um the people who trained with the thumb
for five days and seeing their
relationship with
uh with my design change into um this
kind of deep connection with with this
kind of extra
uh thing that they wore all day all week
sorry
um yeah it was it's been fascinating
fascinating exploration
um into yeah how the brain responds to
augmentative technology
and paulina the participants had an mri
scan
before and after using the thumb
what what specifically were you able to
pick up from that
yeah as i said before what we did speak
about is that
their hand representation changed and uh
i think that's very interesting because
that's not something trivial i mean
we've known for a while that our brains
are
incredibly plastic and we've known that
the way our body is represented in the
brain is related to how we use our body
in daily life
but we have never expected that such
changes
could occur within such a short time
span i mean our participants only
use this town for five days and just to
give a little bit more context
our lab works very heavily with amputees
and we see that you know even decades
after amputation
the hands in the brain of all these
people that lost their hands um
looks remarkably stable and
um here just five days of having an
extra finger
and yet we see those changes in the
brain and um i think it's very exciting
i think that's
very interesting um and also
you know we can learn a lot from that in
terms of how to design augmented and
prosthetic devices for the future
and did you find that the changes that
you established in the brain were were
they long-standing
did they last no i mean i cannot say
that they were
we invited about 12 participants to come
back
for one more scan a week after they
finished using the time
and we actually saw that most of these
changes have diminished
uh so if anything in our case uh they
were quite short-lived
but of course we don't know if we
prolonged the experiment
they were wearing and using the stamp
for say a month or two months whether
that would be the same
but here in the specific case the
changes were not
nocturned and danny obviously we're
seeing these
technological advances um due to people
like
yourself um but have you been satisfied
to discover whether the brain can
actually cope with these
these advances yeah satisfied i'm not
sure
but it's exciting it's it's it's
thrilling to see um
yeah that technology can kind of uh
change the brain in that way
and what do you envisage for for your uh
invention
in the future what sort of areas of use
do you perhaps
think it might be helpful for um just i
mean the
exciting uh use cases at the moment is
um you know changing
uh the hand into potential bi-manual
tasks so
um people using um usually using two
hands
um and can now kind of use the one hand
um or
perhaps even um four oh wow
danny claude and paulina caleb thank you
very much for speaking to us
this morning about the third thumb thank
you thank you
let's uh catch up with the weather now
with kirsty could you do with a third
thumb
i couldn't operate you're clicking i'm
just thinking for the weather but also
to when i'm trying to do my daughter's
hair put in plaits french flat maybe the
thumb could help me do that
that would be genius i need all the help
i can get
all right let's take a look at the
weather because it also needs all the
help it can get at the moment we've got
more wet
and windy weather coming through today
looking further ahead
hopefully things will settle down from
the middle of next week
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we have got some bright
spells to enjoy this morning but make
the most of them because this wet and
windy weather is moving in from the west
already affecting
parts of ireland and northern ireland
and quite strong and gusty winds coming
in along with
the rain so expect a spell of a few
hours of rain today that band of rain
will push its way
from ireland over the irish sea in
towards parts of western britain as we
head through the morning
ahead of that a few showers will develop
across england and wales
maybe the odd heavy one we have got some
swells of sunshine hanging on across
northern scotland the northern isles and
eastern england
and some sunshine will come through
later across northern ireland and
ireland as the rain clears but could be
some heavy and thundery showers here
now that rain will continue to clear
eastwards tonight but lingers over
northern scotland
tomorrow a very wet and chilly day for
northern scotland
sunshine and showers elsewhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the time is at 7 44 still to come on sky
news breakfast a look at the newspapers
with the broadcaster and diamond and the
editor of the sunday express michael
booker
[Music]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los
is to tell the angeles this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
[Music]
boy we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm skye's chief
correspondent
[Music]
we're enormous explosion has just come
down i think it was a monster just
landed in between us
[Applause]
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people and putting them in for trucks
you either live and recover or you die
[Music]
okay so that's like a walk that's the
way yes
we help you understand the world with us
the past 24 hours the soldiers have been
attacked on a number of occasions
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked
[Music]
we hear shotguns being fired and also
tear gas is being
put around the information on this
could bring down the entire network not
just in iraq and syria
but across the world
[Music]
oh
my name's ella i'm an environmental
activist and founder of the end period
plastic campaign
you might be thinking why period
products what's so bad about them
they're the fifth most common item found
polluting europe's beaches
they're more commonly found than straws
or coffee cups
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air
at drop-off and pick-up times
[Music]
a band of heavy rain and gusty winds
will slowly move eastwards across
ireland and the uk today
much abition will start dry with sunny
spells but a scattering of showers will
develop before a band of rain moves
eastwards
from ireland and northern ireland the
rain will be heavy at times and
accompanied by strong winds it will feel
cold with temperatures below average for
the time of year
once this band of wet and windy weather
clears it will be followed by bright
spells and heavy showers in the west
with a risk of
hail the showery weather will keep the
oak pollen
risk at low to occasionally moderate
over the next few days
the main risk of pollen remains tree
pollen with small amounts of grass
pollen
spores will increase temporarily after
rain
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
back with us now to take us through the
newspapers the editor of the sunday
express michael book and the broadcaster
and
diamond welcome back to you both
starting with you first of all
anne and the sunday telegraph
and this story about the vaccination
program the fact that the vaccines
seemingly are effective against the
indian variant so good news there yeah
it is good news and as mick was saying
about an hour ago
it was very depressing news last week
when we were
hearing more and more about the indian
variant and i know friends of mine were
turning to me and saying
oh is this what the future is going to
be like there's going to be more and
more complications
just as you thought you were coming out
of the woods um
things you know another complication is
set up and the indian strain looked as
though it might be a very real threat to
us however now we
hear from the scientists um that our
vaccines are our uk vaccines are
particularly effective
against the indian variant almost as
effective as they are against the kent
variant which is very very good
um the uh a double dose of the fisa
vaccine gives you 88
um protection a double dose of the
astrazeneca
60 plus which would sound as though
they're not quite there
to 100 but apparently that's almost as
good as vaccines ever get
um and particularly even more effective
against the likelihood of being very
very seriously ill
having to be admitted into hospital or
dying from covid
so basically the news is very very good
and
we should celebrate that and it's good
to see good news
on the front of the newspapers at last
um it does make you feel better
yes you can exhale somewhat uh to the
times michael
dominic cummings uh back in the news for
why
yeah well next wednesday he's well if
he's
his eyesight's all right and he can find
the room uh
health and sciences select committee uh
to talk about you know
various things about what's been going
over the last year
regarding the pandemic now it looks as
though he's getting according to this
piece by tim shipman in the sunday times
he's getting
all his armories together to uh have a
right good goal
at various people who he perceives to
have not listened to and have done wrong
in particular
boris johnson the prime minister and
matt hancock the health secretary
now in this it says he's like uh the
sniper in the day of the jackal and he's
getting ready to shoot to kill and
there's a a lot of tough match or
political language in this
about how he's you know this loner who's
ready he's lurking out there somewhere
ready to uh
fire lots of salvos but when you think
about it a lot of people
lost a lot of trust in this man last
year and i think
it's going to be difficult for those
who want to believe him and want to
damage the prime minister so
maybe people in the labor party who have
already
said that he hasn't got a reputation so
he's going to be uh
very interesting to see what he comes
out with there's talk that he's got lots
of uh whatsapp messages
uh from various people in power
documents possibly although he could uh
it says in here that they're ready to
look at the official secrets act if he
breaches
anything to do with that but it does
look as though he has got a lot of
scores to settle
yesterday while most of social media
would seem to be enjoying eurovision
he was tweeting about how matt and
hancock
had backed this idea of we were trying
to reach
herd immunity he also said that the
three lockdowns could have been avoided
if there had been any plan
at all that was in place again
looking to blow particularly matt
hancock so it looks as though he's ready
for a fight but as it signs off in this
piece um is he like one of the japanese
soldiers who was still fighting the
second world war a number of years
afterwards not realizing
it was over so something an analogy that
he made
about people who didn't like brexit so
we'll wait and see but it should be
quite interesting on wednesday
yes yes eyes will certainly be on him on
wednesday
to uh the express and and uh with all
the
the recent stories and issues regarding
the royal family the express is sort of
looking at
how the the queen has um kept an even
keel and going back to royal duties and
doing what she always does
that's right and literally an even keel
because she visited the aircraft carrier
hms elizabeth
uh yesterday in portsmouth and a
magnificent spectacle it was too because
i'm on a cruise ship right now and we
went past that
and it looks fantastic and all of the
aircraft were par and and the
uh helicopters were all parked out on
the top deck um it's an enormous
ship and uh she went to visit everybody
um
one of the little highlights in the
story there is that on
amongst the crew was a chief petty
officer who was aged 40
and his son who was also serving on the
ship
and that's quite an unusual thing which
the queen noted herself to see a father
and son
serving alongside each other on the new
aircraft carrier
but i don't know whether i'm just
getting a bit old and soft but it is so
comforting somehow to and stabilizing as
you said
to see so many pictures on the front
papers of the queen
um looking regal so resplendent in
bright red
out doing her duty yesterday despite all
of the things that have happened
uh and you know some of the bad news
that has surrounded the royal family
just recently and of course
uh us all suffering the year of covid
and everything
to see her out and about doing her thing
which she does so well i don't know
there's something uniquely comforting
about that and
many of the papers are playing on that
yes there she was yesterday i mean
honestly i can't tell you what an
impressive ship that looked like
even in the rather dark and murky
portsmouth harbor yesterday
um it's still a bit windy and blowy
outside but um she looked magnificent in
that bright red
yes no absolutely i think you know
everyone whether you're a royalist or
not it's just quite nice to see her
smiling
on the front of the sunday express yeah
it's nice to see her smiling
uh let's just finish up with um you
michael
um russian spies
yeah well uh the ben wallace the defense
secretaries on the front of the
telegraph saying that they're uh
they're our biggest enemy at the moment
the russians but they seem to be playing
around a little bit and they've been
sending messages apparently to
mi6 um they've been sending word puzzles
like crosswords
and little puzzles in an envelope it was
addressed to mi6 to
friends of russia in the uk and in it
there was a little puzzle which had just
apparently the answer was a yes or no at
the end of it
and so what the henry jackson society
the think tank think is this is just a
sort of reminder that they're out there
they're busy they're looking around and
they're having a bit of a snoop around
but they're having a bit of fun as well
with it as well so it's slightly spooky
but the uh
the spies are out there but they're
they're out for a laugh and they're like
a little bit of a crossword as well but
we'd like a cross word or two with the
russians too
intriguing isn't it uh just a kind of
heads up we're we're still here
uh michael and and thank you very much
for taking us through the papers this
morning hope to see you soon
still to come on sky news breakfast an
official study says both the pfizer
and astrazeneca vaccines are effective